or boubacar vous êtes ancien médiateur à
la mairie de gennevilliers de 2013
jusqu'à ce jour du 13 juin 2019 ou vous
êtes victime d'une interpellation
brutale boukaka c'est un grand frère
voilà ce que l'on vit voilà et boubacar
il sort d'une réunion est là qu est ce
qui se passe qu'est ce qui s'est passé
le 13 juin 2019 on va voir les images
après mais expliquez nous ce qui s'est
passé bien j'étais à proximité d'un
square et d'une structure éducative
d'accord avec un jeune en train de
discuter à genoux rekik était en réunion
avec vous juste avant un poste un jeune
de la ville
en troquant les discuter de la can la
coupe d'afrique des quartiers qui
s'était pas s'agenouiller d'accord
ensuite y'a un moment qui s'adressent à
nous en nous disant qu'elle a perdu sa
fille à nous montre la photo savoir si
on l'ait pas vu ça nous a fait peur sur
le coup mais on n'a pas voulu montrer
parce qu'elle était déjà affolé
ensuite j'ai posé une série de questions
savoir comment s appelle sa fille sous
la dent fois qu'elle l'a vu comment est
ce qu elle est habillée et au passage
lui ai demandé s'il y avait quelqu'un c
est la musique non je dis pas je vais
aller voir en scooter si votre talent
vous attend pas devant chez vous pendant
ce temps là vous vous appelez la police
pour signaler la disparition samedi
qu'elle confond pas très bien le
français ce qui fait que le jeune avait
qu'ils étaient jeudi d'appeler pour elle
moi je vois en scooter devant chez elle
se trouve la petite revient de 3000 main
deux minutes plus tard et quand j'arrive
et une voiture qui égaiera une
intersection
j'ai prête pas attention il s'engage pas
du coup je continue mon chemin la maman
récupère sa fille elle éclate en
sanglots elle pleure alpar et quand elle
paraît à trois personnes qui descendent
de la voiture en question
le premier se présente en tant que
policier eh ben je les trucs que c'est
nous qui les avions appelés pour signer
la disparition et que c'est bon la
petite halle avait été retrouvé ni non
on n'est pas là pour ça on fait juste
des vérifications étaient ok pas de
souci je demande s'il veut même pas pu
ou les papilles de mon véhicule
il me reste ou demanderait tout en temps
voulu du coup il tourne autour de moi et
me regarde autant voir et son deuxième
collègue il arrive et lui j'étais moins
cordial et mamie contre mon scooter il a
commencé à me palper et je les entends
parler en fait et il s'entend dire que
je correspond à un profil du couffin
voilà moi je leur ai dit mon nom prénom
ce que je fais dans la ville
et qu'enfin chez lui par la personne
qu'ils cherchaient du coup vous ont pris
pour quelqu'un dont moi même ont
confondue avec quelqu'un je pense mais
même quand ils ont su que j'étais pas la
personne en question ils sont allés
jusqu'au bout maintenant alors on doute
là vous vous fait interpeller regardez
la vidéo de l'interpellation
m c'est pourquoi j'ai vu sept enfants
avec qui travaille mes couilles boubacar
je vous sens aigu de revoir ces images
franchement ça va mieux sans plan
psychologique depuis mai ouais de les
revoir et de revoir des images comme ça
on prend pas en fait tous ici mais la
question qu'on se pose c'est comment une
voie là d'un simple contrôle ça peut
s'en venait mais comme ça et c'est ce
qui se passe voilà c'est ça une chose
que vous
disque on voit que ça s'est passé ce qui
se passe c'est que l'agent qui m'a
attrapé par les parties intimes
quand on était encore à proximité du
scooter il a mis ses mains dans mes
poches et du coup je lui dis que non mes
potes je préfère les vues des tout seul
ça lui a pas plu il a voulu continuer
moi j'ai fait comme ça mais enfin
d'accord pas de papa pas grand chose
quoi et du coup ça va plus c'est de là
qu'il a décidé de mettre au sol et son
collègue qui était venu avec le sourire
et les rentrer dans son jeu et du coup
une fois qu'ils m'ont mis au sol j'avais
d'abord un genou sur la tête
ensuite ils m'ont mis les deux nous sur
la gorge ensuite sur le torse sur le
ventre ensuite j'ai senti une pression
entre les jambes moi je pensais qu'il
n'avait pas fait exprès que ils mangent
en baie et qu'il allait marcher sans
faire un trait sur ma cuisse et quand
j'ai senti que c'était ciblé et qui
l'écrasé parties intimes
bah du coup l'achat mais qui faisait
exprès ça m'a fait rire les douleurs et
5 à attirer les adultes qui étaient dans
l'espace éducatif et si j'ai parlé de
l'espace éducatif c'est parce que
c'était à trois jours du bac et dans les
petits jeunes qui étaient là-bas
lestement et qui réviser le bac et ma
petite soeur bref moi j'avais aucune
raison que ça monte autant en épingle
donc sûr que ça lui a pas plu le fait
que je lui dise que je préfère vider mes
poches tout seul d'accord et du coup bah
voilà et ça en fait vous avez un peu
résisté
c'est même pas de la résistance parce
que ses mains il les a mis dans la poche
du coup il a bien vu qu'ils avaient rien
une batterie externe seulement
et si j'avais réellement réalité ne vois
pas pourquoi est-ce que je n'avais pas
été poursuivi pour rébellion autres
alors là pendant cette interpellation
policiers plantes les clips scooter dans
les côtes de boubacar ce dernier niait
les faits lors de la confrontation et
pourtant grâce à cet arrêt sur images
peuvent que vous n'avez fourni on
constate que ce coût a bien été porté à
regarder
du scooter
[Musique]
alors bruno pomart on se tourne vers
vous êtes un ancien du raid
boubacar la danse qui nous raconte c'est
exactement le contraire de ce qu'on a
vécu rien on se dit là il ya un souci
alors est ce qu'il ya un manque de
discernement de la part de la police
s'il ya un abus de pouvoir de la police
la situation effectivement ce que je
retiens moi mais c'est des images a pour
une fois mais que boubacar je n'ai pas
entendu insulté les policiers sont
toutes les interventions
c'est ce que je ressors de 7 cette vidéo
est ce que les policiers
ce qu'on voit à travers cette image
encore une fois c'est le problème de
notre société le problème des jeunes
nous a faites partie vous êtes médiateur
nous étions jeunes et de la police c'est
à dire qu'à une attention extrême dès
qu'il ya une canalisation quelle qu'elle
soit et ça tourne on le voit vous vous
êtes terrorisés ça se voit oui les
policiers sont aussi terrorisée que vous
c'est ça le problème et je pense que ce
type d'interpellation effectivement que
derrière sierro risée que les policiers
lui ont ils relevé mais si si si la
tension et les présente les policiers de
la tension est présentement n'est pas
dans la même position c'est moi qui ai
deux jouent sur la gorge
j'appelle moi qui me fait planter des
clous dans les côtes j'interviens
d'ouverture à la rigueur où ils ont tout
ce qu'il faut pour mobiles pour me
mobiliser moi j'ai rien du tout
j'interviens ce que vous dites oh non
mais je suis d'accord mais je vous dis
c'est une même sur le même jeu par
rapport à ce que vos noms et collègues
est ce que vous avez ressenti sur
renault ces interpellations
c'est pas pour les blogs on va pas se
mentir c'est comme partout on en pack
avec les filets jaunes
on en parle avec les jeunes voilà qu'on
voit à chaque fois souvent il ya 90% de
bons et lé 10 % bové qui font du tort
aux 90 autres pour cent est ce que là
dans ce cas là est ce qu'on peut
considérer que qui ça a été un petit peu
trop loin et que l'interpellation là
vous imaginez après dans l'est dans les
quartiers quand ils voient boubacar
revenir et qui raconte ce qui s'est
passé je sais bien positionné médiateur
il va donner après comment ça peut sont
venus mais parce que derrière on va il y
en a car quelqu'un qui est considéré
comme un grand frère dans les quartiers
quand il va revenir il dit je me suis
fait interpeller alors que j'ai rien
fait alors toi quelqu'un justement vous
imaginez alors que c'est quelqu'un qui
fait rien justement qui essaie d'aider
les autres jeunes
mais cela derrière c'est ce qu'a confié
une enquête
boubacar et une en regrettant le plein
coup oui j'ai porté plainte portait
plainte a été un parcours du combattant
avant de porter plainte
on m'a prévenu qu'une démarche qui
plairait pas du coup on va proposer deux
médias
sinon j'ai refusé on m'a demandé si je
pensais qu'en portant plainte ne serait
en sécurité ou la part dont on m'a
demandé si je pensais qu'en portant
plainte de sécurité ben oui en fait
c'est votre bon de porter plainte et oui
mais la joie leur avis une policière les
policiers et les colis s'est ensuite
nettement les brûlis six en activité
pension n'y a pas d' enquête
administrative
j'avais croisé bas il ya eu la
confrontation au mois de juillet
d'accord pendant la confrontation ils
ont tous nié
on essaie de me faire passer pour
quelqu'un d'énervé quelqu'un d'exciter
quelqu'un qui a pas fait c'est faciliter
la tâche
sauf que ce jour là je suis sorti du
commissariat 20 minutes après donc même
si ce qu'ils disent c'était vrai
quoiqu'il à le faire ou de dire qu'ils
ont mal fait leur travail dans les faits
quand même échéance c'est dire la même
chose sans daisy dansions quand
d'évidence il ya un problème
moi j'aimerais que bruno ne tourne pas
autour du pot c'est pratique effective
fini entre ce qui est expliqué et les
images qu'on a vu il y à un
dysfonctionnement de la police tu dis un
manque de discernement mais qu'en termes
exquis ces choses là sont dits oui mais
une connerie qui a été fait il faut le
reconnaître plutôt que de dire tout on
al'air terroriser les pollutions pas
l'air terrorisé du tout lancé qu'il a
très peu été confondu les policiers ont
dit qu ils m'ont dit qu'ils
correspondent à un profil donc assez
pour les gens qui n'ont joué à 8h26 donc
boubacar amont et niveau ont pris pour
quelqu'un d'autre c'est ça mais même en
ce moment où ils vous ont pris pour
quelqu'un d'autre
ils ont continué l'interpellation
musclée c'est ce que vous voulez mais en
même temps il n'est pas violent il n'est
pas moi je pense quand même qu'on a que
quelques images
il ya une enquête on peut pas conclure à
la paz est sauvé je voulais c'est quand
même et je ne va pas faire la loi dans
mes chansons
une honte à sa barre abc a besoin à un
moment il faut arrêter
voilà mine de rien madame de la fayette
défendre l'indéfendable
alors que non mais tu défends pas la
défendent un gain de 10 rondes et le
terreau de discernement on a pu croire
olivier pollution en rien en disant que
ce qui se passait obligatoirement c'est
une faute
si les sollicite pas besoin de mettre
les mains dans les poches etc c'est non
on n'a rien à dire on n'a pas dit
laurence haye et qu'on était contre la
police a mis hier vous l'avez bien vu
là on dit qu'il ya dysfonctionnement ils
n'ont rien à dominer mon témoignage d'un
boubacar et on voit les images je suis
désolé boubacar cisse avait été un
menteur et si boubacar cqeer délinquants
20 minutes ans qui n'auraient pas porté
plainte
je pense qu'il n'aura pas été aussi bon
sinon parce que tu l'auras il aura
accepté la médiation je suis désolé
voilà il n'a pas accepté la médiation
donc c'est ça veut dire ce que ça veut
dire oui ils sont tous que la médiation
c'était officieux s'était pas quelque
chose d'officiel bien sûr mais voilà
pour enterrer les choses à lui que non
c'est pas coeur avait des choses à se
reprocher je pense qu'il aura exercé sa
réalisation fait pas dit ça mais je
pense qu'il faut toujours quand même
avoir du discernement
ouais une enquête si on croit que tout
est en rapport aux agissements de la
mairie c'est quoi c'est que il faut
arrêter tout vous dire prenez le premier
on dirait monsieur claude j'ai vu plein
de deux policiers qui font extrêmement
bien leur travail et pour la plupart et
le fond extrêmement bien ça des images
comme ça ça leur fait très très mal
et c'est justement je vous dis qu'il
faut et csrh comme ça qui font qu'après
ils peuvent plus se rendre dans les
quartiers un petit peu chaud c'est des
images comme ça qui font qu'après quand
il est interpellé un jeune est bas qui
s'est fait interpeller par des caïds de
la police et qui font l'équipe en
écaille débat après derrière ils sont
plus agressifs
donc il ya un effort à faire des deux
côtés je suis désolé laurent seillier ya
pas les torts d'un côté la police n'a
pas tous les temps il faut d un
prisonnier côté de la version civile
cyril ce qu'ils font hier on a vu un
policier qui nous a fait rimer
d'antimoine à la fin on était
complètement d'accord il sait qu'il faut
démontrer ce kid ce que démontre cette
image ces images là c'est la tension
extrême quand même qu allah c'est ça et
ça ne donne pas les policiers si le
manque de discernement ça sera sûrement
bien et on contrôle etc ok mais on a
véritablement problème de société c'est
que nos policiers ont sont de plus en
plus tendues qu'elles interviennent dans
n'importe quelle opération quelle
qu'elle soit et là malheureusement c'est
tombé sur moi karim et que peut-être
effectivement il ya eu
manque de discernement sincèrement non
mais je pense cyril que tu as posé en
quelques mots très justement la
problématique on a l'immense majorité
des fournisseurs de police qui sont
respectueux des codes de déontologie qui
font leur boulot dans des conditions
difficiles qui sont des policiers
république et puis on a quelques cow boy
saran de la police nationale qui se
croient tout permis qui ne respectent
pas les règles et qui saute sur tout ce
qui bouge ça existe aussi deux qu'ils
sont minoritaires mais ç'a donné la
majorité à mon avis combien de voix mais
une fois c'est dévastateur
si les pasteurs non seulement parce que
si boubacar
c'est un citoyen lambda c'est
dévastateur parce qu'il va plus croire
la police
il va raconter son histoire à ses
proches et ça va générer un climat de
que de défiance dont on n'a pas besoin
et c'est doublement dévastateur parce
que c'est plus qu'un citoyen lambda
l'un des quartiers ça médias les
médiateurs vous allez dire que boubacar
c'était un référent qui non seulement
est des références sur lequel la police
doit s'appuyer non pas alors qu'il soit
une balance
parce que c'est pas ça le sujet mais
parce qu'ils parlent aux jeunes il leur
parle pas qu'il se comporte bien pour
qu'ils choisissent le beauchemin ne fait
pas ça ça te mènera rien fait si ça te
mènera d'un et ça si utile pour les
factures de commun comme en fait preuve
certains parce qu'il a raison qu'un camp
voulait que les jeunes l'écoutent
ensuite merci de nous le dire
les jeunes m'ont dit n'avoir les
yonnaises ont dit à mes boubacar les
jeunes ils vont écouter parce que je
pensais quand même 8 et chacun m oui
mais une personnalité dans le quartier
mais là où ça me faisait de tête voit ça
dans un quartier
notons boulot même pas nous un quartier
sensible qu'est ce qui vous ont dit les
jeunes après m'ont dit wade médiateur
regarde ski de fond à la saisine ce
qu'ils peuvent nous faire à nous mais
boubacar qu'est-ce que tu l'horreur et
prenez un espoir a dit il y avait des
mecs bien et les mecs pas bien et que
dans la police il y avait des mecs béret
wii s'est vendue partout vous savez quoi
6e et un policier en uniforme qui m'a
dit continue va jusqu'au bout de sa
démarche
crois moi tu as plein talent est
entendue il est en uniforme pendant
toute l'année j'étais en contact avec le
commissaire de gennevilliers et avec le
maire de la ville et à chaque fois en
fait pourquoi est-ce qu'on en est là
parce que entre le mois de juin et le
mois de mai mois d'octobre à chaque fois
c'était des menaces et des intimidations
je vais te faire la totale à dramé je te
connais c'est pas très flatteur d'être
connue par la police s'était que ce à
dire qu'au bout d'un moment je me suis
dit je vais me protéger je
et c'est pour ça que j'en ai parlé donc
il ya combien de situations qui passe
aussi dans ce dont je veux bien qu'on
dise oui il ya des brebis galeuses est
assise à sa cahute des alliés quand même
c'est un des gens quittent encouragé
dans la police pour tenir ne lâche pas
bien c'est ce qu'ils feront tout ce que
je dis mais malheureusement c'est en off
ça mais ça existe
oui ça existe ça reste un os oui mais
c'est yahia leur parce qu'il ya une
corporation qui à un moment donné a
peut-être du mal à faire son ménage en
son sein deux comme il ya des jeunes des
quartiers comme tête du mal à dire oui
il ya aussi chez nous des brebis
galeuses qui font chier qui donne cette
image c'est donc dans les corporations
dans les communautés c'est souvent
difficile
en revanche là où il faut pas baisser la
garde je pense il faut continuer de dire
qu' il ya une immense majorité de
policiers qui fait son job correctement
et qui sont les alliés des gens qui sont
en insécurité
et puis à des cowboys effectivement ce
qu'il faut condamner qu'il faut dénoncer
comme tu le fais jamais ça soit je
voudrais qu'on sorte des relations qui
lient duel entre entre policiers compare
un peu des pratiques policières
là je suis nostalgique de la police de
proximité par exemple
normalement la police de proximité sont
jaloux les médiateurs normalement non
parce que dirige depuis qu'ils savaient
que les faits les médiateurs et donc ne
jamais ça nous allait venir
c'est nicolas sarkozy qui a enlevé la
première et deuxième chose sur la
méthode de boeck la cage sur la méthode
de plaquages elle-même pardon en
haillons ici on a eu la famille shaw via
ce sont des méthodes qui pour l'instant
ne n'ont pas été remises en cause
officiellement dans la doctrine tu
remplaces parcours à christophe clerc
s'est quasiment fait de virer pour ça en
fait on en mairie
gmail est tueur en place par qualcomm en
l1 mais ça me colle ici les amis
nationale des centaines par jour où tu
vas pouvoir sous début de l'émission à
laquelle a parlé du film les misérables
le sujet de l'exposition moi cette image
me font penser à ce film là que j'ai
trouvé assez réussie parce qu'en fait
ils n'étaient pas manichéen c'est à dire
que dans le film que moi j'ai trouvé
vraiment bien on voit un cow boy à un
policier qui est vraiment un sale mec et
on voit en face des gamins qui à la fin
alors tirent au mortier dessus donc
c'est ressemble un peu à ce qu'on voit
au quotidien
moi quand je vous écoute j'ai ma carte
je vous appelle par leur prénom ce que
je connais pas votre nom je me dis ce
que vous avez vécu ça existe on est
parfaitement au courant le problème
c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'on entend un
témoignage comme ça on a l'impression
que ça devient la vérité absolue et on
invente les aime de violence non mais ça
fait vraiment regardé comme un rat
qu'elle a foncé dans la brèche pour
parler des méthodes de la police etc
vous avez une partie du paysage
politique en l'occurrence d'extrême
gauche qui vous dit c'est des violences
policières c'est un système faut lutter
pour moitié des diverses comme la police
doit changer ses méthodes d'intérêt
selon will à 61% dans évidemment à 39
son ouvrage très vite beau dommage
oui je vous les pensez évidemment par la
police et aurélia 27 ans jeune fille qui
s'est suicidé il ya quelques jours
qu'ils étaient engagés dans mon
association d'ailleurs qu'elle est au
devant des enfants de quartiers pour
travailler le proxy voitures voilà lui
rendre hommage est rendu hommage à la
famille parce que je sais que ce soit y
aura ça c'est ça c'est dramatique
voilà vraiment grosse pensée pour la
versys irin aurélia et je voulais
absolument que vous en parliez ce soir
boubacar merci d'avoir été avec nous